i have got the creepiest social media
story that i have seen in many many
weeks
this goes to the mayor of huntersville
this small little town stacy phillips
mayor of huntersville
sends out a tweet to gay children
asking them to slide into her dms she
says
if you're a kid
living in a don't say gay state and feel
like you don't have an adult to talk to
i got you
you're welcome to slide into my dms to
talk
to share
to express yourself confidentially
it'd be an honor to be your auntie by
blessing
you're perfect just the way you are
i am a very peaceful guy
i am about as chill as they get
even
compared to other people in the
conservative movement you know a lot of
conservatives they'll they get really
angry all the time especially
conservative commentators and they yell
and they get really hot in the face and
steam comes out of their ears and that's
not me
okay i am pretty calm i am pretty
peaceable
if
if you
have a private conversation with my
child if you establish a private
relationship with my child specifically
to talk about sex
you better run you better start running
you better run directly to the police to
turn yourself in that would be the best
option for you if there is one thing on
earth that could impel me to violence
that very likely would impel me to
violence
it would be that
hey
hey someone else's kid
slide into my dms it's a very
flirtatious phrase
just slide into my dms and we can talk
about your sexual desires i'd love to be
your auntie oh yeah i'm your little
auntie slide on in and we'll talk about
sex
10 year olds 11 year olds 12 year olds
run
run i please we were talking about
threats on social media first of all
that's the craziest threat i ever heard
on social media
that sort of thing
is
extremely creepy and also it's the
logical consequence of this kind of
politics of radical sexual liberation
now in in this woman's defense stacy
phillips
i bet that she did not mean this in a
sexual way i don't who knows maybe she
did maybe she didn't but
i would bet that she didn't
i would bet that she just believes
that
sexual liberation is the most important
political battle that we have right now
and parents have no right to raise their
own children
and it's very important that children
pursue whatever sexual desire they have
even if that means mutilating their
bodies even if that means pretending
that they're the different sex and she's
going to be the great liberator
over the oppressive parents who are who
are just keeping their children
constrained you know by things like the
laws of nature
right now you've got to go to
bankonyourself.com
knowles do you really control your
retirement money if you've got a 401k or
ira or similar retirement plan the
government controls it they decide how
much you can borrow and when you must
pay it back and you'll owe taxes and
penalties for taking money out too soon
or waiting too long even though it's
your money and thanks to our
skyrocketing national debt who knows how
much you'll have to pay in taxes during
a retirement that could last 30 years
bank on yourself is a better way to grow
and protect your hard-earned money
guaranteed predictable growth and
retirement income with no luck skill or
guesswork required in fact bank on
yourself has a 160 year plus track
record of positive growth tax-free
retirement income you'll know what your
tax rate will be in retirement zero
under current tax law which protects you
from the coming tax tsunami you are in
control you have control of your money
without government penalties or
restrictions on how much income you can
take for when you can take it you get a
free report right now with all the
details on how adding bank on yourself
to your financial plan can help you take
back control of your money go to bank on
yourself dot com slash knowles that's
bankonyourself.com knowles wlas this
information is for educational purposes
only and it's not a solicitation for the
purchase of any financial product all
guarantees are based on the claims
paying ability of the insurer
i'm so glad you liked that clip now
please ring the bell subscribe maybe
leave a comment head on over to apple
podcast spotify stitch or google play
wherever you get your audio podcasts
subscribe to the michael knowles show
m-i-c-h-a-e-l-k-n-w-l-e-s
s-h-o-w leave a five-star review we'll
see you next time
[Music]
[Music]
you